let's say i've got some subspace v
that's a plane in r3 so let me see if i
can draw it
respectively well let me draw some plane
in r3
maybe it looks something like that
that is my subspace i think that's good
enough let me see if i can draw it even
a little bit better than that there you
go
so that is my plane in r3
this is v
this is a subspace
subspace and let's say that i have some
other vector x any vector in r3 so my
vector x looks like this
that is my vector x
now what i want to show you in this
video is that the projection of x onto
our subspace and let's say that this is
our zero vector right there i want to
show that the projection of x onto our
subspace
is the closest vector in our subspace 2x
so let me let me draw that out and maybe
it'll make a little more sense so the
projection of x onto the subspace will
look something like this
it will look something like that
that right there
that green vector right there is the
projection
of the vector x onto our subspace v
that's our vector x now let's take some
arbitrary other vector in our subspace
let's take some uh let's just take this
one
this is just some other arbitrary vector
in our subspace let me draw a little bit
differently let me draw it like that
let's call that vector let's say that's
vector v that's clearly another vector
on our subspace that lies on that plane
what i want to show you is that the
distance
the distance from x
the distance from x to our projection of
x onto v is shorter than the distance
from x to any other vector from the
distance from x to any other vector and
obviously the way i've drawn it it looks
pretty clear that this line is shorter
than that line but that was just a
particular choice that i picked let's
prove it that's general so what i want
to prove is that the distance between x
and its projection onto the subspace and
the way we can get that is essentially
just take the
length of the vector of x
minus the projection
the projection of x
onto my subspace
this length right here is this length
right here
is this length right here and actually
let me call this vector so x minus the
projection of x onto v
that's going to be
this vector right there
let me do it in a different color i
don't want to reuse colors too often
that's going to be that vector right
there we could call that
a
call that vector a it's clearly in the
orthogonal complement of v because it's
orthogonal to this guy that's the
definition of a projection actually so
this is
equal to a
my claim what i want to show you is that
this distance a is shorter than
is shorter than any distance here is
less than
is less than or equal to
the distance between x and v
where v is any member so that's this
distance right here this vector right
here
that distance right let me draw this
vector
the vector x minus v looks like this
it looks like that
that is the vector x
minus v right if you take v
plus x minus v you're going to go to x
so what i want to show is that this
distance the length of a of the
difference between x and its projection
is always going to be less than
the distance between x and any other
vector in the subspace so that is x
minus v
so let's see if we can prove that
so let's figure out let's take the
square of this distance so the square
of x
actually even before we let me do that
yeah let me write it that way so let's
say x
so we want to concern ourselves with the
square of the distance of x minus v
where x is some vector in r3 and v is
some vector in r3 that's also a member
of our subspace it sits on this plane so
what's the square of this going to be
well x minus v is equal to
is equal to
this vector let me draw a new vector
here
it is equal to
this
group let me draw in this yellow it's
equal to this vector
it's
equal to this yellow vector plus a right
x minus v is this magenta vector that
starts here and goes there clearly equal
to this yellow vector plus this orange
vector so let me call that
yellow vector b
now what is b equal to well b is going
to be equal to
b is equal to
the vector
this vector this green vector which is
the projection
the projection of x onto v
minus
minus this purple vector minus this move
vector i guess minus v that's what b is
so we could write x minus v
as being equal to the sum of the vector
b
the sum of the vector b
plus
the vector a
plus this vector a
so x minus v is equal to b plus a and if
we're taking the this if we're taking
the length of x minus v squared that's
the same thing as the length
of
that's the same thing as the length of b
plus a squared and that's just equal to
b plus a
dotted with b
plus a
which is the same thing as
b
dot b
let me write that a little bit neater
let me write it
down here this is going to be equal to
i'll switch colors
b
dot b
right b dot b plus b dot a plus a dot b
so plus 2 times a dot b
plus a dot a
plus a
dot a
now a and b are clearly orthogonal b
is the difference between two vectors in
our subspace the subspace is closed
under addition and subtraction so b is
going to be
b is a member of our subspace a is
orthogonal to everything in our subspace
dye definition
so since a is clearly a is orthogonal to
b a is in a by definition is going to be
in the orthogonal complement of the
subspace this is going to be
zero and then
this right here will simplify to
the length of b squared and then this
right here is going to be plus
the length of a
squared so we get the distance between
x and some arbitrary member of our
subspace squared is equal to the length
of b
right here plus the length of a squared
now a was the distance between
between our vector x and our projection
right that's what the definition of a
was a was the difference between our
vector x and our projection now this
this number right here is going to be at
least 0 or positive so this right here
is definitely going to be greater than
or equal to a squared or another way to
say it
another way to say it is that the
distance between x
minus v
squared is definitely going to be
greater than or equal to the distance
of a squared
of a squared or the distance between x
minus v
this is still going to be a positive
quantity length is always going to be
positive is greater than or equal to the
length of vector a
or what's that length of vector a a is
just this thing right here so let's
write our result the length of the
vector x
minus v
or the distance between x and some
arbitrary member of our subspace is
always going to be greater than or equal
to the length of a which is just the
distance between x
and
the projection
of x
onto our subspace
so there you have it
we've shown and the original graph kind
of hinted at it that the projection the
projection of x onto v
is the closest vector in our subspace
to x it's closer than any other vector
in v to our arbitrary vector in r3 x and
we've prune it right there